can you guys take me back to day one uh
maybe susan mark bob you guys can talk
about this
uh being the creators of the show the
first time that you stepped on set
when you're about to start filming
what was the feeling like about to get
this thing off the ground
it was oh my god the budget has been
slashed dramatically
because it was the it was the gift shop
uh
remember when we saw oh yeah wasn't it
very early in the shoot when we saw what
the gift
our idea of what the gift shop was it
turned out to be a table with a few
pens and t-shirts on it which was the
joke about the gift shop which is that
my character wants to build a gigantic
gift shop and exploit
and so he's built something very big
yeah
of course production delivered something
very small circles within circles
that's how we write it was a very
ambitious
it script it was i remember the an early
draft
uh began with an enormous helicopter
shot
i remember that mark yeah that was yours
it's missing
that's still not bad if superstar goes
to season seven
i'm putting it in
uh but you know to answer it sincerely
we
were thrilled to actually get it in
front of the camera after so many years
of
writing it reconceiving it and
repackaging it
so yes and and you ended up winning
something like like 13 gemini's
um acting awards for pretty much
everybody like
it was so well received and even now i
was i was going back on uh
on youtube watching the episodes that
are available
and the comments from people are always
so glowing like i love this show
i remember the show like whoever was
thank you for posting this
um or it was the thing that made me want
to get into theater
i i don't know if you ever set out when
you're creating something to to think
about the effect you're going to have on
other people or the accolades you might
be getting um
but that must have been nice validation
for you guys going through the
going through the seasons yeah i had a
terrible
fear that actors we knew would hate it
that was really my biggest fear because
it's so easy to get it wrong and it's
usually done wrong usually the actors
are
well it's fine to make actors pompous
but we also we sort of wanted people to
feel that what they did
conceivably mattered and that was a
tricky thing to get right so
it mattered a lot that people in our own
community
liked it and felt and i think we've all
had this experience you get
you meet someone from australia who has
a
small theater company and they say oh my
god you're just writing about
our company so that's when you really
feel you've done something
that has some value because people see
themselves in it
the solution to to susan's worry was to
put everyone in the community
in the show
it's true yeah we admired all our worst
critics so
including those two right there frankly
yeah the number of theater school
students i think particularly in america
who found it early
and then still still pass it on it's
really always very moving
but i'm not sure when we knew that not
for a long time after
yeah no we didn't know we didn't know no
it's
it's it didn't seem like it had a hope
in hell
and is that why you agreed to do it they
could never do another season but by the
end
i thought we could do 32 or however many
plays
i mean we did you actually think any of
you that it would go on
like this and then it would have been
planned but
really selfish and went to broadway
we didn't have a plan past the first
season at first right we only we
conceived it as
as six as a sort of one-off thing but
then
um the network started to say you know
this is good enough to go
multiple seasons and then uh it was
really susan in her brilliance who
who came up with the idea of youth
middle age and old age and three seasons
of things and arrows
am i wrong i lied and said in that
meeting that we had
always conceived of it and it's
neatly a trilogy i had seen a painting
a dutch painting of three boats
youth middle age old age the old boat
being out at sea with tattered sails the
young
sprightly schooner in the foreground and
i bored bob and susan with this
and now you're boring all over the world
and now i board canada all over it
yes or do tell us more about the boats
well i haven't told you yet about the
middle boat which is really
us right now
[Music]
to your point about hiring you know the
whole community
can you talk to me about hiring and
working with rachel mcadams and not
shortly after
um the show was on your show was on she
kind of
did some very big features and and broke
out into the rest of the world
i'm not aware of any work she did after
swings and arrows this is all new
rachel yes
she was brilliant in the show and she
was
really really delightful to work with in
fact
and we had of course conceived the you
know eventually the three seasons to be
about her character and her experience
but but then her career took off and we
had to reconceive the show
um you know well one day
so yeah right we had we had a very
limited time that we could work with her
after
her she really took off yeah we had like
a few days a handful of days we could
shoot with her in season two
to write her character out of the show
it was immediately clear she was
talented right from the beginning i
think it seems
yes yes yeah yeah which is why we wanted
to base the whole series around her
yeah it was very selfish of her to have
a successful career while we were
like that luke kirby opposite her
whatever happened to that guy
yeah yeah i hope she sees this and feels
really bad about it
notice she's not on this call
have you had the opportunity to go
beyond a third season
had you thought about what that might
look like or what that might be
well the honest answer is no because we
actually
thought it would be very cool to write
ourselves out of a job
and to finish and to finish it because
the last play
was leer and it had to have a sense that
you know
this is what was new and exciting about
a limited series back in the day things
came to an end
and you could really take people on a
journey and you weren't winking and
nodding and saying oh
we'll come back next year so so uh it
was satisfying to do
but although as paul points out we
missed out on 32 other plays that we
could
have tackled had we gone another way
but it had i think it had a poignancy
that we really you know that only comes
when you
are really writing the last episode of
your story
yeah it you're talking about how
different theater companies from all
over in australia or the us
uh people will remark and say that that
story is
uh about me it's about my theater
company why do you think that
the particular way that you wrote these
characters and the way that this
was um presented felt so universal
it's funny because the the fear i think
from the network right to the beginning
and some critics was that it was going
to be
too inside and people wouldn't be able
to access it but i feel that
we really did um we were able to capture
a community and this feeling that this
was a specific community
with parts that uh
readily translated to any kind of
community any kind of big
project that many people are involved
with so
a workplace drama yeah a workplace yeah
that's what we considered it yeah yeah
dramady and i think it was pomeranama
kamarama as mark called it yes
but the funny thing i found about it was
that it
it didn't i mean it wasn't wildly
received here in canada and then not at
first
and it started sort of moving around and
was moving around in the most
old style viral way possible people were
burning dvds i got
sir richard air called me to do a show i
didn't know him i said how do you even
know me
he said because it's his favorite show
and he's given it to everybody he knows
an english theater which means that's
everybody
but the best experience i had i was
shooting a really
pretty awful show for warner brothers in
l.a and this
uh big huge ia guy teamster came
stood next to me and said so uh the guys
and i really like that slings and arrows
oh yeah everybody on all the lots were
watching we passed the discs around
a lot better than that piece of shooting
right now
i don't i've never been able to quite
understand why
how it was what it was exactly that made
it
go around the world like this yeah is it
a testament
to that idea that you shouldn't try to
play to everybody and rather just play
to
you know each other audience or your own
story or just yourselves i guess
well i always thought that the the
reason why
bob susan and i were able to write like
this is because
i think we were just getting to the age
where it's
legitimate for you to turn around and
say
oh what have i been doing in in the you
know my work my life in the arts and
where is it going
and it was very sincere and we've had
completely different and completely
similar experiences and
it was apt if that's a word do people
still use that it's a good word
three letters
it's also we infused the whole thing
with our own personal crap
which i think made the characters very
relatable but there's tons of
because there was tons of we wrote the
whole thing around susan's uh
kitchen table i thought
yeah no but we all sat around her
kitchen table and we talked about
everything we were dealing with in our
lives and
and you know outside of the theater and
that kind of
i think colored all of the made the
characters themselves richer
and i i think i think it's really about
how relatable some of these
these characters even though they're
extreme um ended up being to people
when you're you know when you're sitting
there and you're thinking about putting
all your crap
out on the table and out on the page is
there is there any
hesitation ever for you to go well
people are going to recognize that
that's
my story or people are going to
recognize that that's a problem of mine
and i might not want to put that out
there or is that
go against the whole concept of of like
i guess theater and being brave and
putting things out there
yeah that's the thing about theater that
you realize early on is that you can be
very personal and
really expose yourself and no one really
knows for sure that's you
you know it's a character so
martha and paul i want to ask you guys
what it was like uh working together
oh we're still together
[Laughter]
no working i was well
uh paul was paul had had a lot more
experience on
set than i had at that point so i was
so it was real it was wonderful for me
to be to have a lot of
scenes with with uh with someone who
really knew what he was doing it was
much more relaxed so that was
uh that was very odd or also that there
were things
that you that all the little
insecurities that come up we could
i could always we could talk about that
on our way
to and from the from the set and over
breakfast
and things like that and um and like who
we hated
also just like yeah just brings up what
something i wanted to add to what you
asked before too i think like one of the
reasons that it was so much fun to do
was also that the writers of the writers
of the show were in it
um that was part of its magic and that
we all and that
it was this you know our relatively
small theater community that was growing
as we were doing the show
in terms of the young people that were
coming on the set where like we were
people had
had worked together before we had that
sense of recognizing someone
and all that often you're working on a
tv set with someone that you just met
five minutes ago
and so there was there there was a there
was a real lit layer of richness and
resonance of people that were already
familiar with each other and had shared
words and and i think that had a lot to
do with the like why that why
why the the excellent writing and to
begin with just
took off too
you